Muhammad, how you doing,
>> man? How are you?
>> I'm pretty good. Pretty good. What's on
your mind?
>> That's good. That's good. That's good. I
mean, um, first of all, I want to before
I ask a question, man, finally, I'm
talking to you. I've been I've been
watching a lot of videos of you and
[__] both mine and all that, but I want
to I want to give you I want to give it
to you that you have courage. you have
courage after going out with after
coming on all these videos with Hutman
and basically it's all over the internet
and you're still coming out here and
trying to prove that Jesus is God.
>> Mhm. Um my question is after and you
probably had that from Shehman and other
people that that have been there is in
Mark 10:18
when the rich young man came to um Jesus
and told him how oh uh oh good teacher
how can how can I gain eternal life?
That answer of Jesus himself when he
told him to not call him good first of
all only God is good
>> right
>> he didn't call him he he didn't say
don't call me good
>> no no he he he said who why do you call
me good only what god is good right
>> yep that's that's that's very different
from saying don't call me good right
>> no what is what is that telling you
>> what is that isn't isn't he denying
being good
>> no he's not a denial of being good would
be like what you said if he said, "Do
not call me good." That's a denial of
being good. Or, um, I'm not good. Th
those are denial statements. But simply
saying, "Why do you call me good?
There's none good but God alone." That's
not a denial. That's a thoughtprovoking
question that he's asking to him based
on a truth that only God is good. So, if
he's saying that Jesus is good, then
he's really identifying and he's saying
that Jesus is good in the absolute
sense, then he's really saying that
Jesus is God. And he wasn't ready for
that. As you see when you read the rest
of the context, he wasn't ready to
follow Jesus cuz he didn't truly believe
that he was good.
>> Yeah. But it's he's literally telling
you, "Why do you call me good? Only
God." And when he says only God is good,
he saying that only God is good. Okay,
let's let's let's go on.
>> Don't Don't you believe Don't you
believe that God asks questions
sometimes to make a point?
>> What do you mean?
>> Like, so for example, there's um I mean,
you have Quran verses, but to my mind,
what pops up? Are you a Sunni Muslim, by
the Yeah.
>> Okay. So there's a there's authentic
hadith that talk about how Allah
descends to the lowest heaven, right?
And when he descends to the lowest
heaven, he asks he says, "Who is it that
is praying to me? And who is it that
supplicates to me?" He's asking these
question. Now is he asking out of
ignorance? Like does Allah really not
know who's praying to him? Does he
really not know who is offering up
supplications to him?
>> No, he knows it.
>> Right? So these are this will be an
example of Allah asking questions as a
demonstration or to make a point not
that he really doesn't know or that he's
ignorant. So in the same way when Jesus
is like why do you call me why do you
call me good? There's none good but God
alone right it's not a denial of him
being good but he's asking the question
to make a point to the to the to the
person and the point is proven later on.
So when he tells you that only God is
good, that that for you is not a
distinction, that he is not God.
>> No, because Jesus literally refers to
himself as being good as the good
shepherd. He refers to himself as being
the perfect one who is without sin.
There's no way that God is good that G
in a way that Jesus isn't. Jesus is good
exactly how God is.
>> Yeah. And also goodness is going to be a
property of your nature. So all we'd
have to do is show that him and the
father have the same nature and then by
definition he would that statement of
only God being good would apply to him.
>> That's called pure blasphemy my friend.
>> It would be blasphemy if he wasn't God.
Muhammad if he's not God it would be
blasphemous but if he's God that that's
that's through understanding of the
church unfortunately
>> when Yeah. Well well I know that the
church told you guys that but you're
trying to use the church for that.
None of None of us none of us quoted the
church, Muham, but we haven't quoted the
church yet. We just talked about
scripture.
>> No, no, no. You were taught by the
church and that's how you have this uh
ridiculous explanation.
>> Who who who were you taught by? You were
taught by who?
>> The the Sunni school. Yeah. What school
was you taught by? What what school
within Sunni Islam were you taught by?
>> Uh I was taught by Prophet Muhammad. But
I I have uh most of my knowledge most of
my knowledge is from the one who kind of
embarrassed me in front of everybody,
which is
>> I got you. So, so you get so you get
your information from Shik Usman who
follows a certain sect and school within
Sunni Islam. So, you're getting your
stuff. Hold on, let me finish. Let me
finish. Islam.
>> Let me finish please. So, you're not
getting your information directly from
Muhammad. You didn't talk to Muhammad.
You wasn't there with Muhammad. You're
getting it from Shikman who says that
there's multiple messiahs in Islam and
says that Muhammad and all the other
prophets are messiahs. You agree with
him on that?
>> There's only one messiah which is Jesus.
>> Okay. So, then you already disagree with
your teacher. So, stop bringing Yeah.
Shake Shak I'm sorry said that there are
multiple messiahs in Islam and you just
disagreed with him.
>> No I I for me dude first of all I I I
told you what did I tell you? I get my
information from the brother
I know that I know I I know that you're
still in shock of the embarrassment of
it's okay.
>> I know I was I was I was in shock at how
he embarrassed himself. I was in shock.
I couldn't believe it. I was shocked
that he would embarrass himself. Really?
Did you see the video? I was there. I
was there.
>> Did you see
the video?
>> Believe it or not, I was there in
person. Can you believe it?
>> And when you were there when I was there
in person, guess what, bro? Listen. When
I was there in person and he said, "All
prophets are Messiah in Islam." I was
shookth. I was like, "Yo, hold on a
second." I couldn't believe my ears. I
was shocked. I couldn't believe he
embarrassed himself like that. You're
absolutely right,
>> bro. Bro, bro, you can you can disagree
with him all you can, but the fact is
>> when you did not know how to answer a
lot of questions and among them who told
you is is is Jesus is God all knowing.
>> Wait, wait, hold on. Wait, wait, just
just really quick cuz you said that
there are a lot of questions that he
asked me that I did not know how to
answer, right? And you're saying that
that one of them was
>> does is God all knowing? And you're
saying that I did not answer him on
that?
No,
>> you did not know how to answer him on
that. You so when I you had this one
>> so when I walked him through the
scripture on the context of Mark 13:32
and he didn't even know the context and
when I took him to a parallel verse in
first Corinthians and he was going the
wrong way going towards the Old
Testament instead of the New Testament.
You're telling me that I didn't know how
to answer him when I was walking him
through the Bible that he so-called has
tabs and markings all through?
>> No, you Let me tell you something. When
he told
>> Take care, man. Get off my stage. Get
off the stage.
>> Your two hands, bro. It's crazy. There
you go. There goes your logic.
>> Thank you, man. Appreciate it, man.
Shake Uman Iben Fibben footnote. You
know how he got that nickname, Iben
Footnote? By talking to me. That's
that's how he got that uh that new
nickname because he brought a footnote
thinking that it was a hadith that he
doctorred up to try to say yes I have an
authentic narration that all Messiah all
prophets are Messiah. He brought a
footnote and embarrassed him. I was
shook. I was I was shocked. I couldn't
believe it. So yes, I was shocked at the
embarrassment. Frederick, how you doing?
>> Hello.
>> How you doing?
>> Yeah. Can you hear me?
>> I can hear you. You disagree with
anything?
>> Yeah. I want to talk about the hadith.
Okay.
>> Yeah. And not this hadith. The hadith
about uh regarding the crucifixion of
Jesus
>> where he says, "Father forgive them for
they do not know or Lord forgive them
for they do not know."
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So what about that hadith?
>> Yeah. I have seen many of your you know
audience going crazy over that argument
saying oh my god this is Jesus and uh
there's no any reputation for this. So,
I'm not So, I just want to see if I can
deal with this.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, it's on topic, right? You're
talking about the crucifixion.
>> Yeah. Yep. It's pretty.
>> Yeah. So, uh if you're not going to pull
it up, I can just say why it's not about
Jesus.
>> Yeah. Uh so, first of all, I want to
know why is it about Jesus except the
statement or oh Lord, forgive my people
or is it all the hadith?
>> Say that again. What's what's the point
you're saying now? I didn't really
understand you.
>> Yeah, I said it's everything. What I
mean is everything in the hadith is goes
exactly like what exactly happened to
Jesus when he was
>> So why are you denying that it's Jesus
when it fits him perfectly?
>> I don't think it fits him perfectly to
be honest.
>> I'm I'm I'm confused. You just said that
it fits Jesus and now you're saying that
it doesn't.
>> No, I'm asking you. I'm asking you. It's
the hadith.
>> Oh, you're asking me? Yeah. Yeah. I'm
saying is the hadith very completely
identical to what happened to Jesus when
he was on the cross.
>> I I wouldn't say that everything in here
is word for word identical. I would I
would say that the reference is uh is
what is you know matching.
>> Yeah, I will yeah I will agree with you
that when somebody looks at it at the
first time they will assume that it's
Jesus. Even the second, third, and
fourth time they see it, they'll be
like, "Yeah, it's Jesus."
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> There's nobody else that this fits.
>> So, uh, how was Jesus able to wipe the
blood off his face? Or his forehead?
Okay. His forehead. I said his forehead.
>> Or does it say his forehead? It says his
face. Wiping the blood off his face.
>> No, wait. So, you uh
>> It says wiping the blood off his face,
not his forehead. I'm just offering you
a logical explanation for if Jesus was
wiping blood off his face on the cross.
It's it's possible. You there?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Sorry, my bad. Can you hear
me?
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. So, I asked you, can you agree
that no human being is able to wipe the
blood off his forehead while being
hanging on a
>> Does it say forehead or does it say his
face? Yeah, I'm going to break that
down. But can you agree with me or say
does it say his face?
>> Yeah, in this hadith in particular, it
says his his face.
>> Okay. So, I'm not worried about his
forehead.
>> No, but the narration says his forehead.
>> The narration says his face, doesn't it
say that?
>> No. Yeah, that is the hadith. I'm
talking about the narration itself.
>> The narration.
I'm confused. According to the
narration, we're looking at the the
hadith is the narration, right?
>> Yeah, you can say that. That's not what
I meant.
>> Bukari 6929.
What is he wiping? His forehead or his
face?
>> Yeah, it said his face. I'm going to
explain this, but can you listen to me?
>> I'm listening.
>> Okay. So, I'm sure you know that this
narration in specific uh does exist in
Sah Muslim, right?
>> Sure.
>> And in I guess uh I guess so. uh the
it's all the same narration but we can't
say it's the same hadith that's why I
said the narration says his forehead but
this hadith in specific in Bkari 6929
says his face but we have in another
hadith in another books of collections
another collections of books say uh he
was what uh part of his face in specific
he was wiping and what is hilarious is
alkar himself
in his book al
says uh not no he is not the one he's
saying this uh he mentioned the same
narration and mas uh tell us tells us
what part of the face of the prophet he
was wiping. So this is why I said the
narration says his forehead not the
hadith and we actually see this uh that
thing in the gospels itself themselves
like for example
>> it says his people beat him and where he
was wiping the blood from his face and
saying this is sunb maja 4025 and suicai
bkari the one we just saw um he's wiping
the blood off his face right there it
says that in his face and then we go
down sahim
wiping the blood from his face. So in
Sai Muslim, in Sai Bkari and in Sunb
Maja, the hadith says he's wiping the
blood from his face.
>> Yeah. Can you go to 757 in the same
website.com?
>> Do what? What's the What's the source?
>> Uh I can tell you the spelling alab.
You can I don't know if you can actually
type, but you can go down.
>> Yeah, you'll find. Yes. Yes. Yeah. Yeah.
757. 757. Yeah. Can you read for
>> Yeah. So he says he wiped the blood from
his brow saying,
>> "Yeah,
>> Allah forgive my people for they do not
know."
>> Can you scroll down for the Arabic?
Yeah. So I can already make the argument
that the brow is the forehead. It's
basic English. But the word in Arabic is
jabati which is directly translated to
his forehead. This is for any Arabic
speaker. He can confirm this. And I and
I can make the argument that according
to the other narrations, you have three
of them in your three authentic sahi
books in the first six. You got Bkari,
Muslim, and then also Sunna Maja that
all say that he's wiping his face.
>> And so with that being said, it just
says his face,
>> bro. You can still wipe your brow even
like like a
>> Wait, wait, wait. Uh Nick, I just want
to say something that yes I agree with
you in Sah Muslim Maj and Bkari they say
his face but the issue is they don't say
uh the narration doesn't say sorry the
hadith doesn't say which part of his
face explicitly
>> I just wiped
>> which part of his face if he was wiping
>> Did he just wipe his brow just now?
>> Yeah, your forehead.
>> So why couldn't Jesus do that being
crucified? No, I say your forehead.
>> Bro, you just read it where it said
brow.
>> No, I I also said it's translated
directly to forehead.
>> Is your brow on your forehead?
>> Yeah, it is. But the word Yeah. Wait,
wait.
>> Yeah, it says I I don't care what you
say. There's a lame argument that you're
trying to bring. Uh, it says face there.
It even says brow there. I just wiped my
face. I just wiped my brow with
>> your brows on your forehead. Like, bro,
>> I just wiped I just I just wiped it all.
So what? So we see that your argument
trying to use this against the
crucifixion doesn't work. You can be
crucified and still wipe your brow, wipe
your face. Doesn't matter
>> on your forehead, right? Wait, you said
you don't care about what I'm saying
because
>> because what you're saying
>> what you're saying doesn't fit the
hadith, bro. Or
>> wait, because I said jabati is
translated directly to his forehead. You
said you don't care about what I say
because basically I didn't show you that
for that jabi is indeed directly
translated to his forehead. So that's
why because this lack of evidence
>> can you can you demonstrate can you
demonstrate to me that when it says his
face it doesn't mean his face it means
his forehead specifically.
>> Yeah because the other hadith give us
>> No. Can you show me in Sai Bkari and Sah
Muslim and Maja when it says he's wiping
his face it doesn't it doesn't it means
his forehead actually. Yeah, they say
his face in general. That's the
>> Thank you. I I I appreciate that. So,
next, what's your next argument?
>> Wait, wait, wait. We're having the same
argument, man.
>> You're just missing missing some uh
something.
>> Okay.
>> Yes, we have.
>> Thanks for coming.
>> That's so bad.
>> Hello.
>> Yeah. Hi. I only came up
>> I only came up because Nick, we had a
conversation. We're trying to have a
conversation. Yeah. Um couple nights ago
and uh I think metaphysics like took
over from there. When you said that
Jesus was called Yahweh in Jeremiah 23.
>> Yeah.
>> You saying that only the true God has
the name Yahweh?
>> Yeah. The only other person that's
referred to as the full tetetrogrammaton
is the Messiah there.
>> Yeah.
>> Um could could we read the verse?
>> Sure.
>> All right. In his days, um let me see.
This is Jeremiah 23:6. In his days,
Judah shall be saved and Israel shall
dwell safely. And this is his name
whereby he shall be called the Lord or
righteousness. You said this is a
reference to Jesus, right?
>> Yeah.
>> All right.
I want to get All right. So, let's uh I
want to go to and only only the father
only sorry. Only only God could be
called Yahweh the Tetrogrammaton.
>> Yeah. That's the only person that could
be called the entirety of the
Tetrogrammaton. Yeah.
>> All right. All right. So Jeremiah 33:16,
same exact construct
>> about Judah, right?
>> In those days Judah shall Judah shall be
saved and Jerusalem shall dwell safely.
>> Yes.
>> And this is the name wherewith she shall
be called.
>> One second. One second. One second. Bro,
you're a faster. Hold on.
>> Lord,
>> it's the exact same. It's the exact same
phrology. It's the same Yahweh that is
used here for Jerusalem.
>> So tell me why. Hold on. Tell me why a
person could be called Jerusalem and a
place sorry a person could be called
Yahweh. God could be called Yahweh. A
place could be called Yahweh. But you're
saying that Yahweh is only refer refers
to the true God.
>> Yeah. So if you actually would have
listened to what I said, I made it very
clear. What I said was yes, the only
person that can be called the entirety
of the tetetrogrammaton is Yahweh
himself. I did not say that a place
could not be called Yahweh because I
know this dumb argument. I know
Jerusalem is called Yahweh.
>> Who made that rule? Who who made that
rule?
>> Made what rule?
>> Who who said that the only person that
could be called Yahweh is the
>> It is the only person that's called
Yahweh.
>> So Jesus is the only person called
Jesus. Correct.
>> No, there was Jesus for Avis, too. We
>> This is embarrassing.
>> Well, he wasn't.
>> No, it is. It is embarrassing for him
because he's making up new rules as he
goes along to fit a particular way. I'm
making up new rules.
>> If the same bro, if the same word is
used for multiple instances for multiple
different nouns, why are you reserving
it just for God?
>> So if I'm making up new rules, show me
any other person that is called the
entirety of the tetra grammaton.
>> It doesn't matter. I'm not making sure
you were well used for something else.
Correct.
>> Dude, you No, you Oh my gosh. You're not
listening. I said for any other person,
not a place.
>> Wait, why does it matter? What's the new
rule that made that?
>> Because an inanimate place by definition
cannot be God. So it's it of itself
calling him God.
>> So what is God?
>> God is a person.
>> So oh, so God has to be a person.
>> Yes.
>> So when Moses is called God, Moses is a
true God.
>> It says he will be like a god unto
Pharaoh.
>> Well, we went over this already. Is
Moses is Moses is Moses a person?
>> Yeah, he is a person. Yeah.
>> Okay, good. Is Moses is is Moses
identified as Yahweh?
>> No, he's not, but he's called God.
>> Thank you. Do you have a person that's
identified as Yahweh? Not Not Elohim.
Not Elohim. Do you have a person who's
identified?
>> Yeah, we have. No, no, no worries. No,
no, no worries about a place being named
after Yahweh.
>> Do you have a person who's named after
Yahweh? Who's named Yahweh specifically?
>> No.
>> Very good. That's so my claim. So my so
my claim was correct that the only
person that is called the entirety of
hetrogrammaton is Yahweh himself. God
and the Messiah most high God
>> a place is also called by the same
words. I'm I'm trying to figure out
>> I know this dude. I never made the claim
that it wasn't. My claim was that the
only person that is called Yahweh.
>> So why do you say it is reserved only
for one thing or one being if it's used
for other things?
>> Because God is a person, not an
inanimate place. I I don't think you
you're tracking here.
>> No, no. Bizzy, you're you're the one
who's not tracking, brother. Look, it's
busy. Look, it's simple. It's simple.
It's simple.
>> The only person who could be named
Yahweh, who can bear that name is the
most high God, right?
>> So, that's the category he's talking
about. When you go into category of
places, that's not the same category
Nick was talking about. Now, you're
going into the category of an inanimate
place, the city of Jerusalem. that can
rightly be named after Yahweh. That was
not his argument. The only person only a
personal agents that can bear the name
Yahweh is the most high God himself.
>> Yeah. Again, that's that's that's
special pleading though, isn't it?
>> No, it's No, it's not. The scripture
literally says this.
>> Making We're making up a new rule.
>> No, the scripture literally says this,
bro.
>> No. Like, we're literally saying you can
go to the scripture and you cannot find
me a single other person called the
entirety of Grammaton. And you can go
and and you can go to the scripture and
see blatantly that the only person like
literally it's explicitly said that the
only person who can be who is identified
as Yahweh is the most high God.
>> Explicit verses that say that.
>> No see see because the Isaiah right
Isaiah Isaiah's names his name means
Yahweh is salvation.
>> Yeah. He's he's not he's not called
Yahweh.
>> Yeah. Also by the way if you look at
Isaiah as well as Zachchariah Yeah.
Yeah, by the way, if you look at Isaiah
as well as well as I mean Hezekiah, it's
not the fullness of the tetetrogrammaton
in their name. It's only the yud vav.
And again, Dr. Michael Brown on my
YouTube when he came on, he confirmed
this as well that in their names, it's
not y v. It's not the entirety of touch
grammaton in their name. It's just yud
va. That's it. It is Hezekiah.
>> Hezekiah is y va. It's not doesn't have
the hey.
>> What what in what what inse is Hezekiah?
I I don't think I referred to
>> Hezekiah's name has Yahweh in it, but it
doesn't have the entirety of
tetetrogrammaton. It only has
>> Can I Can I read this for you just to
just to make this clear? Just give you a
couple verses. Okay. Um it says, so this
is Nehemiah 9:6. It says, "You are
Yahweh, you alone. You have made heaven,
the heaven of heavens, with all their
hosts, earth and all that is in it, the
seas and all that is in them. And you
preserve all of them, and the host of
heaven worships you. Psalm 83:18, that
they may know that you alone whose name
is Yahweh, our most high over all the
earth. So, can any other person
according to these texts, can any other
person be identified as Yahweh?
>> Not according to the text that you just
read.
>> Yeah. entity be referred to as yelling?
>> Say that again.
>> Could another entity be referred to as
Yahweh?
>> Can another person be referred to as
>> defining entity as?
>> Can another entity be referred to as
>> you defining entity as?
>> An entity is simply something that
exists.
>> Okay, then yes there. Yes, there can be
a place that's called Yahweh. Yes.
>> All right. So, so then we've established
>> So, so according So, according to the
verses that I read you, can any other
person be referred to as Yahweh?
>> Not not what you just read. So, show
show me again because when I read when I
read
>> when I read the orthodoxy, Jewish
orthodoxy on this, they're saying that
Yahweh is just like another name that
you you have, for example, Isaiah,
Hezekiah, you have other names that
includes the name of God, right? uh uh
Israel um uh Ishmael they include some
part of God and this just does not
confer divinity on that entity
it has part of it doesn't have the
entirety of the tetetrogrammaton that's
the point only the Messiah in Jeremiah
is referred to as the entirety of the
tetrogrammaton it has all v
>> but Jeremiah 20 37 33 refers to
Jerusalem
>> in it entirety you're not tracking we
already agree that places can be called
Yahweh. We're saying the only person
that can be called the fullness of the
tetetrogrammaton.
>> Who who made this rule? Which which
prophet made this rule?
>> I'm saying you can even go to you can
just go and look at it. It just that's
how it is in the Old Testament.
>> Look, I'm I'm I'm trying to
>> I think I think this is uh I think this
is not this is what you do when you need
to run.
>> I was busy. If I'm wrong, show me a
single person in the Old Testament
that's called the entirety of the
Tetramaton.
>> Show Show me a Jew that agrees with
this.
>> Show me the orthodoxy. Wait, hold on.
Show me the orthodoxy.
>> Take care, man. that agrees with this.
>> Yeah. Embarrassing. So, he can't kill
me. So, he wants to go to appeal to what
the Jews say. I wonder I wonder what the
Jews say about a uh the Messiah and if
they believe it's Jesus like Muslims,
should we go appeal to them now, too?
>> Mhm.
>> Yo,
>> what's up?
>> Yo, is Jesus God?
>> Yes.
>> How is Jesus God if he's a man?
>> Because he has two natures and one of
those is the divine nature which makes
him God.
>> Praise God, not a man.
>> In the Old Testament, he wasn't a man
until he incarnated. So, is the Old
Testament now infallible?
>> No, it is infallible. He wasn't a man at
the time of the Old Testament. He didn't
incarnate yet.
>> But Jesus was always a man. Yes.
>> No. No. What?
>> Jesus is always a man.
>> No.
>> Yes.
>> No, he's not. Says who?
>> Cuz uh like everyone in the Bible.
>> Show me in the Bible where it says he's
always a man.
>> From his birth. Jesus is always a man.
Yes.
>> From his birth. He's not always a man.
So, in the Old Testament, in the Old
Testament, was he was he was he a man in
the Old Testament?
>> Show me in the Bible where it says Jesus
is God before his birth.
>> That it says what?
>> Jesus is God before his birth.
>> Oh, yeah. You can read Jeremiah chapter
23, the one we just went over.
>> Read it, please.
>> All right. Sure. See? All right. Behold,
the days are coming, says the Lord, that
I will raise to David the branch of
righteousness. A king shall reign and
prosper and execute judgment and
righteousness on earth. Who's this
talking about here?
>> You got to read it slow, man. You're
talking way too fast. Behold, the days
are coming, says the Lord, that I will
raise to David a branch of
righteousness. A king shall reign and
prosper and execute judgment and
righteousness in the earth. Who is this
talking about?
>> So that's God speaking about Jesus.
Where does that say that Jesus is God
before?
>> Right? I'll show you. In his days, you
will be saved and Israel will dwell
safely. Now, this is the name by which
he shall be called, Yahweh, our
righteousness. Why does it say to call
Jesus Yahweh?
>> I don't know, bro. But why? Why does it
say in John 17?
>> Wait, wait, wait. Why are you running
from the verse? I don't know why is God
is God Elah.
>> What
>> is God?
>> Yes. And he's also Yahweh. So are you
going to answer the question? Why is he
called?
>> So So when it says God is the only true
God,
>> answer the question. Why is he called
Yahweh here?
>> That's the probably because all this all
these biblical scriptures have been
corrupted by.
>> So why did you ask me to show you if you
just going cry corruption? But I wanted
you to show me where it says Jesus is
God before he was born.
>> I did and then you cried corruption.
>> Nope. You said that God will give God
God will give a king to the earth.
>> What? It says that Jesus is Yahweh here.
>> I asked you where does it show that
Jesus is God before he was born?
>> Yes. And I showed you right here.
Jeremiah is before he's born. Correct.
>> So you're saying because Jesus is called
Yahweh, it means he was God.
>> Yes. Literally.
>> No. So, can you wait can anyone be
called Yahweh that's not the most high
God?
>> Is the only true God is Elohim?
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait. Is Yahweh not
the only true God?
>> Yahweh is the spirit of God.
>> Is Yahweh the only true God? Yes or no?
>> The spirit of God.
>> It a yes or no. Is he the only true God?
>> No. Elohim is the only true God.
>> Oh, okay. Great. So, why does Isaiah
44:24 say, "I, Yahweh, formed all of
creation alone."
>> Why does it say that Elohim the only
true God?
>> Because Elohim's a title. Yahweh is a
name. So, answer the question, dude. Why
does why does Isaiah 44 say Yahweh
formed all of creation?
>> Wait, let's stop right there. Yeah. So,
in the beginning was Elohim, and Elohim
created the heavens, the earth, and the
spirit.
>> Yes. Because Yahweh is Elohim, dude.
>> Was was the Father before the Son or was
the Son?
>> No. But, bro, are you going to answer
me? Why does it say that Yahweh created
everything?
>> Was Yahweh coexisting with God,
>> dude? Yahweh is God. Are you literally
like, "Oh my gosh."
>> Oh, wait. Wait, wait, wait.
>> You got You got moderation. Just Just
say the word.
>> I know. I'm about to So, Dude, why does
he say Why does Yahweh say that he is
the one that created all things?
>> All right. Show me what Jesus is Yahweh.
>> I just did in Jeremiah. Yeah, bro.
>> Tell me again. Tell me again, please.
>> Tell you again. Nah, buddy. You ain't
listening to Kick Rocks, bro. Kick
rocks. This is crazy.
>> What happens, guys, when you become
Muslim,
>> dude? I'm telling you. Like, bro, this
can't be for real. This can't be real.
Folks ain't locked in, bro.